Hello, Dr. Kevin Cutters here and we're going to talk about bone cancers, mainly primary
bone cancers in this video in this section, and a lot of the primary bone cancers are
adolescent or childhood cancers, and it's very scary for parents. It's very scary no matter
what your diagnosis when you hear the word cancer. We understand that. There's decisions
to be made. If it's a child, you really don't have a decision. You're going to have to
go standards of care. We understand that, but adding some alternative care to the process
can give you a better outcome most of the time. So think about how the cancer got there
in the first place. There's very few cancers, bone cancers, one of them that really cares
a genetic base. So we have to look at what can we do to change the milieu, change the environment,
change the terrain. What can we add nutritionally? What can we look at dietarily? That's the alternative
side. If you have to go or you're choosing to go with chemotherapy, radiation, surgery,
or something like that, you want to do everything you possibly can to support the body through
that as well. Things that you add from an anti-inflammatory perspective, from a specific
nutrient that can help kill cancer cells, can only help the conventional therapies that
you're choosing to do as well. But when you make that choice to add alternative care, it
becomes a daunting task because you're faced with, well, what should I do diet wise? What
should I do with supplement wise? Bioclone has over a hundred different supplements that
are proven to be very helpful with different cancers. So when we take on a patient, we test
them to get very specific. We don't want people on a hundred different supplements. We want
people on four or five specific things that are going to target their cancer. We don't want
to put them on radical diets either. That's that healthy. That takes all the joy out of your
life. We want to just test for what the fuel sources for that cancer and then let's eliminate
or reduce that. We test for frequencies with the right. We test for other therapies as well.
What's going to be the best thing to add for you for your cancer? Because ultimately,
we want your success. We want you to improve your odds. We want you to improve the quality
of your life and have a long, many years ahead of you. Now, ultimately, no matter what you
do, whether you choose to get care with us or not, that's okay. We're going to be praying
for you and we just ask about that you just put a lot of part in your decision as well.